una sera io parlerò di maternità la
maternità ha ispirato vari tipi di arte
ha ispirato ad esempio la pittura
guardate questo questo quadro di klimt
quanta quanta dolcezza quanta serenità
c'è nell'immagine della madre col
bambino oppure la dolcezza in questo
quadro di picasso si evince non solo
dallo sguardo dal dal viso della donna
ritratta ma se vince anche dal dai
colori dai colori di questo splendido
quadro di picasso oppure in questo
quadro sembra che sembra che ci voglia
dire che intorno a questa madre a questo
bambino può accadere di tutto ciò che
conta è lì in quel momento
la maternità però ha ispirato anche
altri tipi di arte la madre è la
protagonista di tante poesie ungaretti
immagina che anche nel momento della
morte ci sarà la sua madre a dare come
al solito una mano perché la madre è il
punto di riferimento di tutti noi
oppure questa poesia di edmondo de
amicis
la scelta perché è legata a un ricordo
personale
chi di voi ha dovuto recitare la poesia
da bambino durante la festa della mamma
alzi la mano io ho dovuto recitarla
almeno quelle che hanno più o meno la
mia età avevano in genere in occasione
della festa della mamma il compito di
recitare la poesia ognuno di noi ogni
bambino aveva
era stato assegnato una poesia a me fu
assegnata questa poesia di edmondo de
amicis
io però non volevo recitarla non volevo
recitarla perché mia madre all'epoca
aveva 40 anni non ne aveva 60 e quindi
ecco mi sembrava offensivo dire mia
madre a 60 anni davanti ai miei compagni
fu bocciata la richiesta che io feci di
cambiare la poesia
ecco umberto saba ci ricorda che i
nostri figli per quanto amorosi come
dice lui ci faranno soffrire le nostre
raccomandazioni i nostri moniti spesso
saranno saranno vani spesso non ci
ascolteranno ma fa parte del rapporto
tra madre e figlio pasolini dice che
l'unica che conosce anche al mondo che
conosce il suo cuore è e sua madre e io
ho voluto riportare anche questa questa
foto della di pasolini con sua madre
qui passa lì masoni non è più un bambino
è un uomo adulto però guarda te lo
sguardo il gesto di sua madre
sono lo stesso sguardo e lo stesso gesto
che una madre può avere nei confronti di
un bambino molto piccolo e quindi
secondo me questo è un po l'immagine
l'emblema che l'amore della madre nei
confronti del figlio non finisce mai
però la maternità in grado di ispirare
anche delle discipline che non vengono
considerate prettamente delle discipline
artistiche e io vi dimostrerò che la
maternità è in grado di ispirare anche
una disciplina come la medicina che
considerata una scienza ma in parte la
medicina è anche un arte perché alcune
idee alcune ispirazioni sono poi quelle
che determinano lo sviluppo di alcuni
tipi di ricerca
certo per ispirare la medicina ci vuole
una maternità molto forte quale può
essere una maternità doppia
questi sono i gemelli di click
anche qua vedete la bellezza diciamo il
sentimento appagante la serenità che
esprime questo quadro questi sono i
gemelli di klimt e questi sono i miei
ecco questa è stata la data in cui si è
verificato l'incrocio tra la mia vita
personale e la mia vita professionale
sono nati capo andrea e margherita sono
qua nel pubblico la nascita di un figlio
cambia la vita di una persona
esiste una vita prima della maternità
esiste una vita dopo la maternità non
che una sia migliore dell'altra però la
vita dopo la maternità vuol dire che
cambiamo il nostro modo di vedere il
nostro modo di pensare il nostro punto
di riferimento il centro del mondo
non siamo noi il centro del mondo sono i
nostri figli perché si è verificato
l'incrocio tra vita personale e vita
professionale
io sono un oncologo mi occupo in
particolare di tumore della mammella e
ogni anno in italia 50 mila donne si
ammalano di tumore della mammella e 2700
di queste donne sono delle donne molto
giovani delle donne al di sotto dei 40
anni
queste donne sono delle donne molto
forti che tutti i giorni ci insegnano
qualcosa quando le incrociamo nella
nostra vita professionale e vedete ci
insegnano che la vita non significa
aspettare che i temporali passino ma
significa imparare a danzare sotto la
pioggia
la tempesta rappresentata dalla diagnosi
di tumore dalla necessità di fare
chemioterapia con tutti gli effetti
collaterali che la chemioterapia
comporta
primo tra tutti la perdita dei capelli
ovviamente in un'epoca basata sul web
come la nostra danzare vuol dire creare
un blog
e questo è il blog che ha creato questa
mia paziente nel momento in cui ha
dovuto fare la chemioterapia vedete ha
chiamato il blog che
la senza paura e non ha avuto diciamo
esitazioni a pubblicare sul blog le sue
foto le sue foto senza capelli o
addirittura la sua foto quando
finalmente ha trovato la parrucca giusta
e vedete in quella a destra e mentre ha
scelto la parrucca e questo momento che
in realtà giustamente viene vissuto come
momento molto tragico devo indossare la
parrucca e per questa donna invece è
stata l'occasione per fare un self come
facciamo noi in tante occasioni della
nostra vita
queste donne sono forti ci insegnano
tante cose però c'è un effetto
collaterale che queste donne non
accettano un effetto collaterale che la
chemioterapia può indurre e che è
rappresentato dalla perdita della
fertilità perché purtroppo la
chemioterapia può avere questo effetto
può far sì che queste donne non possano
poi diventare madri una volta che hanno
terminato il loro percorso terapeutico e
quindi io forte della mia esperienza di
madre mi sono detta bisogna fare
qualcosa bisogna trovare una strategia
perché queste donne non debbano pagare
anche il prezzo rappresentato dalla
perdita della fertilità
come conseguenza della chemioterapia e
lì è nata l'idea
lì è nata l'ispirazione è venuta dalla
considerazione che la chemioterapia e
maggiormente tossica sugli organi che si
riproducono velocemente era ed è
disponibile un farmaco che in grado di
mettere a riposo le ovaie cioè di fare
in modo che le ovaie entri nello stato
di quiescenza
questo farmaco veniva utilizzato
soprattutto per evitare che le ovaie
continuassero a produrre estrogeni che
possono determinare favorire la crescita
del tumore
allora l'idea che è venuta è stata ma se
io utilizzo questo farmaco per mettere a
riposo le ovaie e possibile che la
chemioterapia abbia meno effetti
collaterali perché le ovaie sono in
stato di riposo questa è stata l'idea
per realizzarla è stato necessario
disegnare uno studio clinico portare
avanti uno studio clinico non è facile
bisogna avere delle persone
che collaborino alla realizzazione di
questo studio e io ho trovato tanti
colleghi sul territorio italiano tanti
oncologi che hanno che mi hanno aiutato
a portare avanti questo studio fare uno
studio clinico significa avere delle
risorse economiche perché bisogna pagare
l'assicurazione perché bisogna pagare
tutta una serie di infrastrutture perché
bisognava comprare il farmaco che
all'epoca non era disponibile con questa
indicazione quindi bisognava a comprarlo
indira necessaria vere risorse
economiche alle risorse economiche ci
sono state date dall associazione
italiana per la ricerca sul cancro che
approfitto di questa occasione per
ringraziare pubblicamente perché è una
delle maggiori sostenitrici della
ricerca italiana
insomma lo studio è stato realizzato
l'idea era buona e abbiamo dimostrato
che effettivamente attraverso la
somministrazione di questo farmaco è
possibile ridurre all'induzione di
menopausa precoce quindi la perdita
della fertilità di queste giovani donne
lo studio è stato pubblicato su sulle
riviste più importanti al mondo di
medicina che è rappresentato dal dal
jama
e i colleghi americani della società
americana di oncologia che tutti gli
anni fanno un resoconto per riportare
quelli che sono stati i maggiori
progressi in oncologia ottenuti
nell'ultimo anno e vedete che l'anno
scorso hanno riportato il nostro lavoro
come uno dei maggiori avanzamenti in
oncologia del 2015 e il paragrafo che
era dedicato al nostro lavoro vedete
s'intitolava buone nuove per le donne
che sperano di avere un bambino dopo il
trattamento per tumore della mammella
quindi c'è stato questo riconoscimento
molto importante a livello
internazionale però la cosa più
importante è stata questa pochi mesi fa
le nostre autorità regolatorie italiane
hanno approvato il farmaco con questa
indicazione quindi oggi tutte le donne
italiane possono avere accesso
gratuitamente a questo farmaco per poter
preservare la loro funzione ovarica
quindi diciamo che se oggi in italia ma
anche in tutto il mondo perché ormai
tutte le linee guida oncologiche
mondiali riportano questa strategia come
una strategia da offrire alle donne e
giovani che vogliono preservare la
funzione ovarica dicevo se tutto questo
è possibile bisogna ringraziare i
ricercatori italiani che hanno portato
avanti questa ricerca e like che
economicamente ne ha permesso la
realizzazione
e chiaro che quando questo giornalista
mi ha intervistato per così approfondire
un po questo tema e così con fantasia mi
ha definito cicogna
io sono stata molto contenta mi sono mi
sono ritrovata molto in questa in questa
definizione ora mia sorella non mi
chiama più col suo nome non mi chiama ci
poniamo va bene e mi piace diciamo
immaginare che di aver collaborato a
portare effettivamente dei bambini alle
giovani pazienti che diciamo hanno
affrontato la chemioterapia ma che alla
fine della chemioterapia hanno voluto
fortemente una gravidanza all'ultimo è
nato meno di un mese fa il 20 settembre
è nato questo bambino dalla mia giovane
paziente e devo dire che quando arriva
la telefonata proprio il giorno in cui
sono nati questi bambini per per farmi
sapere come si chiamano quanto pensano
tutti questi dettagli devo dire che
forse questa è la più grande
soddisfazione più grande riconoscimento
al lavoro che abbiamo portato avanti il
messaggio con cui io mi volevo lasciare
che volevo trasmettere è che è
importante che la nostra vita personale
e ciò che di meglio ci accade nella
nostra vita si incroci in qualche modo
con la nostra vita professionale quindi
incrocio tra vita personale vita
professionale
perché è vero che è importante la regola
d'oro che è caratteristica della maggior
parte propria di tante religioni di
tante filosofie non fare ad altri ciò
che non vorresti venisse fatto a te però
a mio avviso non basta bisogna fare
qualcosa di più e quindi secondo me
incrociando la nostra vita personale ciò
che di meglio abbiamo avuto con la
nostra vita professionale forse possiamo
rivisitare la regola d'oro e cercare di
far sì che gli altri possono avere ciò
che di più bello
abbiamo avuto noi grazie